compound interest is something we've
known about for years so this is this is
old stuff but we haven't dealt with it
for a while so i want us to go over um
three quick
sub points underneath compound interest
that's going to form the foundation of
when you think about when you've got an
investment or a bank account or you're
paying something off
it's very important it's kind of
foundational um so let's remember first
what is the formula
for compound interest i'll give you a
clue it also like other things in this
topic start today but it's a capital
um what's it stand for by the way a4
it's not area
amount thank you the amount you end up
with
um you start with some quantity does
anyone remember what's the quantity that
you start with called
it starts with a p principal with an a
okay
um and then we're going to multiply by
this stuff right what do we multiply by
think carefully the compound interest
formula
one plus r okay now there is a formula
that just has an r in there i'll come
back to that one in a second
but for compound interest and this is
why i thought um our example with
lawrence and julian is a nice one to go
to sorry i keep on
i don't know why i've put this so far
away the example that we just did right
there was a kind of one plus r happening
for julian's income right
there was the one and then this r how
much this thing increased by every time
was 15 right so the example that we gave
here was
this ends up being 1.15 it should be a
pretty phenomenal interest rate for a
bank account but anyway
that's what we get here but then we
might have
our money into banking for some amount
of time not just one
year or two years or something like that
so then we need a power up here
right 0.15
yes exactly which gives you this
yeah um what's what do we usually call
the index usually
n and for like a number of time periods
okay all right yeah question
ah okay so let's come to this idea this
is like the basic
compound interest formula basic compound
interest formula um
somewhat hilariously this is actually on
the reference sheet so if you're like
wait what is this again it's it's there
i don't tell you much about it but
there it is even though it was something
we learned years and years ago but we
have to modify this in certain ways
based on time okay and that's where this
next point comes in
right so compounding period let's
actually think about an example here
um let's say we have an interest
on a bank account of say five percent
so what this means is you put a hundred
bucks in your bank account
every year they'll give you five percent
of that right which i guess we would
calculate as five dollars
but that's only if you do it once if you
look once at the 100
in a year okay we would say that five
percent
per annum actually converts to something
different
based on how frequently you compound
right
so five percent would be your interest
rate okay
but then you might say well i might
compound more frequently than once a
year i might do it once a month
um does anyone know how often banks
actually do it
every day they only pay it monthly but
they will
they'll actually do the calculation
every single day okay
so we have to take this five percent you
don't get five percent every single day
you get a small share of that five
percent right
so five percent divided by 360. five
percent divided by 365. so this is
five percent divided by 365
per day right now this is important
because it's going to
affect what our r is and it's also going
to affect what our
n is okay so for example
um if we say let's pick a number of
years like for three years
okay if i would just go to this formula
and just say i'm going to put in all of
the bits and pieces that i know
what did i say let's just start with 100
okay so our amount
might equal 100 there's our principal
we would say there's the 1 plus our rate
0.05
and then we would say well n would be
however many
years you were in there three years okay
but
if we compound daily
our numbers all shift right um our
principle
still stays the same the one
is still the same it's just part of the
formula but like we just said that five
percent per day
changes this r that we're putting in
there right so i would write
0.05 divided by
365 in there right
because you're only getting a 365th
worth
of that interest every single day now
not only has that changed
but you're doing this so many more times
you're doing it 365 times per year
so then this is going to be three lots
of
365 we're not going to worry about leap
years and that kind of thing okay
make sense so the amount of interest you
get each time is so much tinier but you
do it
more frequently now i was wondering
could you get your calculators out if
you haven't already
and at your table with the person beside
you can one of you go ahead and work out
this first value and then can the person
next to you work out
the one underneath what do we get for
each one
so we're gonna get a yearly one and a
daily one
wait for a second i'll get the yearly
one first if that's okay
the yearly one's just this first one
here
seven six two so by the way
just before we go into the next answer i
think parent was there first actually he
was there before the other one but
um we we kind of bake into this process
approximation because we're dealing with
dollars and cents right so i think you
said
five but i'm gonna round this to the
nearest cent
okay um and then okay go ahead and give
us the other number um
one eight two two three zero okay so
i'll get the
sense to two decimal places there um and
i'll write that again but i'm
approximating
okay fantastic so we went from
uh yearly to daily and the difference
ended up being
well that looks like um in
in terms of raw terms right it's like 40
cents
ish 42 cents in fact um but
but when we think about the difference
in the actual interest calculated
right that 15.76 versus 16.18
it's actually a fair proportion remember
the interest rate hasn't changed
at all it's just how frequently we
calculated it okay
so please watch very carefully when you
get given questions
they'll specify the compounding period
and that will change the numbers you put
into the formula
okay any questions on that all right
happy times
all right wait sorry say it again
what happens if it's a leap year
actually that's a good question to pose
i wasn't going to mention it here but i
might as well um over the last few
topics maybe you want to
draw yourself up like a teeny little
table over here
we have been developing in each topic
what we call a model
right um we use models to help us
understand a situation
so let's think about okay when we were
doing
differentiation maximum that kind of
thing and one of the topics we very
briefly looked at was
motion like objects that move right it's
like i take an object
throw it in the air right so for example
i might give you something like
say this
hmm um if we were talking about motion
when you see that letter x what does
that usually denote
displacement very good like where is the
position of something
we might say v for velocity or a for
acceleration that kind of thing
and when you see this the t stands for
time right
so this guy here i wonder if you can
picture this is a face down
concave down parabola right so it's like
oh i throw an object up in the air and
then it comes back down
now a ball will move very close to that
or an object of anything
right but not exactly like wind
resistance that kind of thing
it's just a model but it's a pretty good
one right um what about when we're
looking at
uh continuous random variables and we
gave you guys
a formula which was a model of the
normal distribution do you remember that
it was a function of zed do you remember
that oh boy we're going back towards
before holidays right
i'll help you out there's gonna be a one
on
root two pie is this ringing bells right
you're like oh this was
awful and gross right and i think we had
what e to the
hm there was like uh
do do you remember yeah it was i think
from memory it's like
minus actually i'm not i'm not gonna do
it from memory because i don't trust my
memory
it's a it's a minus a half
z square do you remember that right okay
i'm getting to that right now my point
here is
this gives you like the perfect bell
curve right
and real life is not nice and neat and
perfect like that but it's very very
close it's close enough to be
useful so now here we're thinking about
compound interest right compound
interest
and we've got this guy this guy
which is well if you were to graph this
we actually sort of flagged this on
tuesday if you were to graph it what
would it look like
it would not look like a face down
parabola it would not look like
a bell curve what this looks like
say it again it's an exponential right
like there's some number in here like
1.15
as our example is here or two or three
or whatever
and then this power of n as you increase
this thing just skyrockets
right say that again each year it
increases each year or each day or each
each time period right now this is
coming to max's question right
what about leap years well this doesn't
take leap years into account
as i've just said it but it is close
enough that it can be useful
right and if we really wanted to we
could change this to 365.25
and then you can be like what about leap
minutes and leave seconds which exists
by the way they're a thing
they're like yes but this is close
enough to be useful make sense
okay last point and then i'm gonna set
you loose all of the things we talk
about right now
they all assume things get bigger
right you put money in the bank you hope
you hope that when it comes out there's
more of it right
but that's not always the case what is
depreciation what does that mean
something depreciates in value which is
true i've used the word
in my definition can we not use the word
in the definition
uh moy what are you thinking
okay so so in terms of the formula
here's the formula here
right um i will just change it right it
is
instead of plus it's minus so instead of
one plus r it'll be one minus
r but i wonder like in what situations
does this happen why is my thing
losing value it's when something that
you purchase
or something tangible or not
when when the value of that
decreases over a period of time very
good
so did you catch that it's super
important you get that idea not just the
numbers
it's when something that for example you
purchase an asset of some kind
if if it gets lower in value over time
rather than increasing value right so
generally you did say some cars right if
you've got some special vintage car and
you're like never driving anywhere you
just look after and all that kind of
thing
maybe that will increase in value but by
and large we buy cars to use them
and as you use them they get beaten up
the engine just degrades over times
you're like
this five-year-old car is worth less
than this brand new car
right so this minus here let's just have
a think of an example let's use this um
this 15 that we just talked about right
what if an object was losing 15
of its value over time what would this
become
um i i own a toyota corolla
i bought it for about 28 dollars
okay it's it's a great car okay now if i
were to say
it lost fifteen percent of value over
time
then it's going to be one takeaway one
take away what
0.15 right
and then to the power of however long
you own the car
right now what's this going to become in
here
28 000
one take away 0.15 what's that equal to
zero point 0.85 0.85
okay now this guy is still an
exponential curve but it doesn't look
like
this does it
think carefully right what's happening
to my graph
huh okay so so will's got it right and
actually because so many of you had some
trouble with this i would love for you
to draw this
underneath where you've written
depreciation okay
if you draw yourself a set of axes
right we we know what a normal
exponential curve looks like it starts
low goes high
okay this is going to do the opposite
starts high
goes low but in this particular way
right um it's going to sort of drop
toward this and it's going to slow down
as it goes right the first year
the first 15 that it loses um you guys
have a calculator and i don't
what's what's that going to be worth um
what's 15 percent of 28 000. i don't
actually know what it is
10 is 2800 half of that is 1400 so 1400
2800 which is 4200 there we go okay
some nice teamwork there okay so it
loses 4200 the first year
right but then the year after that it
doesn't lose that much
because the car is worth less so 15 of
less
will be less right um i guess it'll be
be
yes do you like that that was a
technical way of saying it okay so
the only problem is coming back to max's
idea right this is a model
this is not actually what's going to
happen in reality after a certain number
of years
even though this thing approaches zero
my crawler will literally be worthless
right like i'd have to pay someone to
take it away because it should be like
scrapped
right yeah maybe okay very little um if
i can actually get into the scrap metal
place right which might be difficult
so does this make sense uh these are the
key ideas we need to
keep in the back of our minds we've met
them before but i wanted to refresh your
memory